[موسيقى]
من العربيه احييكم وهذه النشره الخامسه
وانا ريما مكتبي نبدا بابرز العناوين
في حفله كامل العدد عشاق كره القدم في
السعوديه ينتظر النجم البرتغالي رونالدو
بقميص نادي النصر
[موسيقى]
السلطات الايرانيه تلاحق اجانب بتهم
التجسس ومدينه كرديه تتحول لثقل عسكريه مع
استمرار الاحتجاجات
الجمهوريون يستعدون لتسلم الاغلبيه بمجلس
النواب ومعركه مؤجله ضد بيض بسبب خزامات
على من يخلف فلوزي
وفي الصين مستشفيات كامله العدد باصابات
على مسافرين الصينيين وتتواعد بالرد
النصر السعودي بعد اقل من ساعتين لحفل
تقديم نجمه الجديد البرتغالي كريستال
كريستيانو رونالدو وصل رونالدو الى
السعوديه حيث
سيقدم نادي النصر السعودي النجمه الجديد
الى جماهيره في حفل سيحضر ثلاثون الف
متفرجا في ملعبه مرسول مبارك بالرياض هذا
وشاهد الموقع الخاص ببيع تذاكر الاحتفال
اقبالا جماهيريا كبيرا حيث
سيظهر رونالدو للمره الاولى بالقميص
الاصفر امام الجماهير وسائل الاعلام
المختلفه انحاء العالم
نعم ريما بالفعل انظار العالم كلها تتجه
اليوم الى ملعب وساحه النصر ملعب مرسول
مبارك الذي سيتم في تقديم كريستيانو
رونالدو بالطريقه مختلفه وبطريقه تحاكيما
تم للاعب قبل ما يقارب 12 سنه او 13 سنه
في ملعب سنتياجو برنابيو في عندما انتقل
الى ريال مدريد قادمه مانشستر يونايتد في
بدايه مسيرته اليوم سيكون الموضوع مشابه
تماما لذلك الوضع وكانه يعيد تقديم
كريستيانو للعالم من جديد
النصر ويقدمه في حفل كبير سيحضره عدد كبير
من
المشجعين فقرات الحفل متنوعه سيكون هنالك
كلمه كريستيانو رونالدو لجمهور النصر
بالاضافه الى كلمه لرئيس نادي النصر
بالاضافه الى اغنيه مخصصه لكريستيانو
رونالدو سيتم تقديمها عبر احد الفنانين
السعوديين الذي سيغنيها للجمهور الحاضر
بالاض الى ان هنالك حصه تدريبيه للفريق
حصه جماهيريه ستكون همم في ملعب النصر
سيكون تقريبا اا توقيت الحفل ساعتين ونصف
كما تشاهدين في الصوره في محيط مرسول
مبارك عدد كبير من الجماهير توافد منذ وقت
مبكر همم للذهاب الى الملعب وهمم الدخول
اليه والاستعداد همم
الحفل وايضا همم مبكرا قدما الالاف من
المشجعين همم نلتقي ببعض المشجعين الرمايه
اذا سمحتي لي همم بعض مشجعين نادي النصر
ارحب فيك اليوم همم كريستيانو رونالدو
وسيرتدي قميص النصر الذي ترتدي للمره
الاولى على ملعب النصر كيف تصف هذا
بالنسبه لك مشجع نصراوي والله شيء كبير
هذا صفقه ممتاز ان شاء الله والله يا رب
باذن الله
ما هي الاضافه الذي التي سيقدمها
كريستيانو
للنصر و للدوري السعودي والمنطقه بشكل عام
بصفتك مشجع اضافه كبيره للدوري السعودي
اولا
ونادي النصر والله ينفع به يا رب
شكرا جزيلا شكرا شكرا
يرغب في عمل لقاء اليوم كريستيانو رونالدو
كنتوا تشوفونا على الشاشات اليوم للمره
الاولى في ملعب النصر والله الحمد لله
كريستيانو فرحنا اضافه كبيره للدور
السعودي
هنا ومعروف الحمد لله ان شاء الله نتمنى
ما شاء الله مشاهدات كريستيانو رونالدو ما
شاء الله قدم ما شاء الله مشاهدات نستمتع
هذه الاضافه حلوه في الدوري السعودي يلا
يا حبايبي ان شاء الله
بس انا حبيتك كريستيانو لانه ما شاء الله
اضافه قويه الدوري السعودي يا سلام حبيتك
يا كريستيانو
ههه شكرا كريستيانو بيوحد الجميع هنا ريما
هذا المشجع قام بعمل شيء عملتها ثلاث مرات
صح
ايوه طيب كيف تشوف كريستيانو اليوم ان شاء
الله
حركه رونالدو
ما يحدث ريما في الشارع الرياضي السعودي
بشيء غير عادي كما شاهدته قبل قليل معي
مشجع التحدي شاهدت الكثير من
المشجعين الهلاليين الذين يشجعون
كريستيانو رونالدو تحديدا هم لا يريدون
النصر ولكن يحبون كريستيانو فبالتالي هم
متعاطفين مع كريستيانو
وسيقدمون اليوم بكل تاكيد لمشاهده نجمهم
الاول في في ملعب النصر بالاضافه الى انه
الطموحات اصبحت عاليه لدى كل مشجعين الفرق
السعوديه ريما بعد قدوم كريستيانو رونالدو
الى النصر اصبح الجميع يطمع بوجود دوليا
عالميين في فريق على سبيل المثال مشجعي
الهلال اصبحوا اصبحت انظارهم الى باريس
وتحديدا الى ليونيل ميسي الذين يريدون بان
اداره الهلال تجربه اليهم بالتالي همم
الكل صار يطبع بوجود لاعب دولي وعالمي
وكريستيانو رونالدو اليوم موحد الجميع همم
في طب ملعب مرسول بارك ليحتفي به ليس فقط
مشجعين النصر ولكن مشجعين كل الفرق
السعوديه
الحدث سعودي بنتياز اول قبل ما يكون حدث
لي فريق معين ولنادي معين سنكون معكم بهذا
التخطيط من الرياض شكرا لك يعطيك الف
عافيه من مرسول بارك انا معي مراسل عربي
عبد المحسن الحربي
وفي السلسله عواجل لا ترد على الشاشه مجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي نرفض اي تحرك احادي
يقوت وضع المواقع المقدس
وايضا نؤيد بقوه احترام المواقع المقدسه
في القدس هذه همم عن مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي ونشدد بقوه
حفاظ على الوضع القائم في القدس وكان ايضا
الاردن استدعى السفير الاسرائيلي لاحتجاجا
على اقتحام ابن غفير باحات المسجد الاقصى
الى ملف ايران فقد نقلت وكاله رويترز عن
مصدر المقرب من لعبه شطرنج الايرانيه ساره
خادم ان اللاعب وصلت الى اسبانيا بعد
تلقيها تحضيرات من عدم العوده الى ايران
وذلك بسبب خوضها منافسات بطوله العالم
والتي اقيمت في كازاخستان بدون حجاب وذكر
المصدر ان ساره خادم تلقت اكثر
بعدم العوده
رغم وجود لها بحل قضيتها
ولفت رويترز الا ان مسؤوليه الامن في
كازاخستان قصص واربعه حراس شخصين
لمراقبه غرفه اللاعبه الايرانيه خوفا على
حياتها
قبل ذلك ذكرت وسائل اعلام ايرانيه ان
السلطات القضائيه في طهران وجهتهامات
لمواطنين فرنسيين اثنين ومعهما مواطن
بلجيكي بالتجسس والعمل ضد الامن القومي
الاتهامات تاتي ضمن حمله الاعتقالات
العشوائيات التي تنفذها سلطات الامنيه
بتهمه التحريض واثاره الشباب
[موسيقى]
في اليوم العاشر بعد المئه على اندلاع
الاحتجاجات في ايران تحولت مدينه جوان رود
الكرديه غرب البلاد لسكنه عسكريه اعاده
السلطات نشر قوات عسكريه في المدينه بعد
التوتر اسرى مقتل متظاهر السبت الماضي
وذكرت منظمه هنغاو الحقوقيه الكرديه ان
السلطات نشرت قوات اضافيه في مدينه جوان
رود وسط استعدادات لاقامتي مراسم مرور 40
يوما على مقتل سبعه اشخاص في المسايرات
الاحتجاجيه او في المسيرات الاحتجاجيه وفي
توقيت متزامن شهدت مدينه مهاباد الكرديه
التجمعات احيا فيها المتظاهرون ذكرى قتلى
الاحتجاجات الذين سقطوا الشهر الماضي
واغلق المتظاهرون في عده مناطق بمناطق
بمدينه مهباد بعد الشوارع باشعال النيران
مرددين شعارات مناهضه للحكومه ومؤيده
لاهالي جونرود في منطلقت احتجاجات متفرقه
في مدينه سندس عاصمه محافظه كردستان ضد
النظام وتايدا للمحتاجين في مدينه جوانرود
[موسيقى]
رغم مضيفه ثلاث سنوات على مقتله بضربه
جويه امريكيه قرب مطار بغداد لا يزال قاسم
سليماني قائد فيلق القدس التابع للحرس
الثوري الايراني يثير الجدل في العراق بل
تسبب ذكرى التي تصادف اليوم القساما بين
المقومات العراقيه
[موسيقى]
وفي سياق اخر وعشيه ذكرى ثالثه لاستهداف
الحرس الثوري الايراني طائره الركاب
الاوكرانيه بالصواريخ واسقاطها بعد جمعيه
اهالي ضحايا الحادثه العالم للانضمام الى
التجمعات التي ستعقد بهذه المناسبه
وكانت عشرات المنظمات وتجمعات دعت في وقت
سابق الى مشاركه نقابات في الاضرابات
ومشاركه المواطنين في تظاهرات مقرره يوم
الثامن من يناير الجاريه
مع دخول العالم الجديد او العام الجديد
هناك امور يجب متابعتها في سوريا فبحسب
صحيفه الشرق الاوسط تلك التحديات
الاقليميه والدوليه الخارجيه ستكون لها
اثار كبيره بدرجات متفاوته على سوريا منها
لقاء لاردوغان والاسد بعد ضغط من روسيا
وكذلك زياره مرتقبه للرئيس الايراني
ابراهيم رئيسي التي كانت مقرره الاسبوع
الماضي
[موسيقى]
وتتابعون في نشره الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
مؤسس بورسعيد للعملات المشفره يمثل امام
المحكمه بتهمه الاحتياله
اهلا بكم من جديد نقلت رويترز عن مصدر
المقرب من قياده الموليه لروسيا ان المبنى
الذي تعرض مؤخرا لقسم
عدد كبير من الجنود تم حجله منذ سبتمبر
الماضي للمشاركه في المعارك ضد اوكرانيا
وكانت روسيا قد اعلنت مقتل 63 جنديا
من قواتها في الهجوم الصاروخيه الاوكراني
على معسكر التجنيد في مكيفكا بالجزء
الخاضع لسيطره الروسيه من مقاطعه دوناتسك
امريكيه الصنع من طراز همارس
[تصفيق]
قبل ذلك اعلنت اقوات الجويه الاوكرانيه ان
الجيش الاوكراني اسقط نحو 500 طائره بدون
طيار ايرانيه صنع منذ سبتمبر الماضي واكد
المتحدث باسم القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه ان
القوات الدفاع الجوي دمر جميع طائرات
مسيره التي اطلقتها روسيا في هجومها
المكثف خلال عطله راس السنه البالغ عددها
84 طائره
من قناه مراسل العربيه رائد الاخبار رائد
يعطيك العافيه ايه ما الجديد ميدانيا
بالاول يعني مستجدات الامنيه
ينعاد عليك
يعني الاعلان الرسمي لليوم من قبل الدفاع
الروسيه حيث اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
عن اسقاطها
لتسعه صواريخ حديث عدا عن السته التي قصفت
منها اربعه مركز تجميل الروسي ايضا لابد
من الاشاره الى ان الدفاعات الجويه
الروسيه اسقطت 13 طائره مسيره بينما قالت
الدفاع الروسيه بان الجيش الروسي قد نحن
مئات الجنود في همم يعني عمليه عسكريه
مضاده ردا على ضربه التي تلقتها القوات
الروسيه في مدينه وقضى فيها 63 جندي قالوا
بانهم نحو وقضوا على مئات الجنود ربما 300
جندي وعشرات الاليات في محاور مختلفه من
المعارك في
بيانسك ولماذا وكذلك في مناطق جنوب بي من
دانيت بالفعل هناك معارك محتدمه ريما ما
زال القسم مستمرا
ومتبادلا ما بين الطرفين
القدائق والصواريخ تسقط هنا باستمرار منذ
الصباح الباكر باعداد كبيره رشققات من
صواريخ التشيكيه وصواريخ جراده سوفيتيه 17
مصابا ليست هناك ضحايا حتى الان لكن
بالفعل السلطات المحليه طبعا الاسماعيلي
ريما السلطات المحليه هنا همم طلبت من
المواطنين عدم مغادره المنازل والالتزام
في بيوتهم
الزوايا الاكثر امنا داخل البيوت حيث ان
القصف لا يستثني المناطق المدنيه
والسكنيه
المرافق الحيويه هناك همم يعني اعداد تسع
محطات كهربائيه وصفت هناك احياء كامله
بدون كهرباء المياه المقطوعه عن المنطقه
همم منذ سته ايام وننتظر يعني ايصال
للمياه المنطقه كامله هناك معاناه اضافه
الى المعارك الضاريه هناك انعطاف حقيقيه
في مسار المعارك القصف شرس جدا
والوضع صعب ريما تفضلي هل من هدنا انسانيه
خلال النهار ساعه نصف ساعه ام ان القذف
متواصل
الاعمال العسكريه بعيده جدا عن الانسانيه
المشاهد التي نراها هنا ريما مروعه ومرعبه
بالفعل الناس يهرعون الى الملاج والى
المنازل المدينه ساكنه والشوارع خاويه
بالفعل المرحله التي تمر فيها العمليه
العسكريه هي لم يسبق لها مثيل بالفعل غير
مسبوقه وكذلك هي همم يعني همم تمر يعني
مرحله جديده عدا عن المرحله التي انطلقت
فيها المعارك منذ فبراير الماضي ربما
الجدير بالذكر والتذكير بان العدد الذي
طرحته الدفاع الروسيه عن الضربه يوم امس
63 جندي ارتفع لتصبح اعداد القتلى 78 حسب
المحلي هنا وهناك 136 مصاب في المشفى كما
ان هناك ما زالوا بين المدنيين والجنون
تحت الانقاض وتعمل وزاره الطوارئ على نشر
والبحث عن ناجي من هذه الضربه القاسيه
بالفعل توعدت روسيا
بالرد والحديث لابد ايضا من الاشاره
الهامه اخيرا ان روسيا قصفت منطقه
وقالت بان فيها مستودعات للاسلحه والذخيره
ومنصات لصواريخ كانت الضربه قاسيه وتواصل
يعني كان على وسائل
همم التواصل الاجتماعي تناقل لفيديو هذه
الضربه وبعض المشاهد بالفعل هناك عمليه
عسكريه همم قاسيه متبادله ما بين الطرفين
ارجو ان تبقى ارجو ان تبقى بامان انت
وفريق العمل شكرا جزيلا لك حتى اللحظه من
دونيتك مراسل العربيه رائد الاخضر
وصلت اوله شحنه شحنه منتظمه من الغاز
الطبيعي المسال من الولايات المتحده الى
المانيا في اطار جهود استبدال امدادات
الطاقه التي كانت تتلقاها سابقا من روسيا
ووصلت الناقله الى احد موانئ بحر الشمال
حيث سيتم تحويل شحنتها من الغاز الطبيعي
مره اخرى الى غاز في محطه عائمه خاصه
وسرعت المانيا للبحث عن بدائل لامدادات
الغاز الروسيه لتجنب نقص امدادات الطاقه
مع استمرار الحرف في اوكرانيا
اجرى وزير الخارجيه لاسرائيل الكوهين
ونظيره
اول اتصال بينهما بعد تشكل الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الجديده وذكرت مصادر العربيه
ان كوهين مرر رسائل من وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي الى نظيره الروسيلا بروف واكدت
المصادر وانا اسرائيل لم تغيروا لم تغير
سياستها المتعلقه بالحرب في اوكرانيا
الى ذلك قال مسؤول في مكتب رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو ان الاخير
ملتزم بالحفاظ على الوضع القائم في المسجد
الاقصى وذلك بعد اقتحام وزير الامن القومي
باحات الاقصى واصبح حراسات مشدده في خطوه
اذنتها رئاسه الفلسطينيه وبلدان عربيه
الخارجيه السعوديه اعربت عن ادانه المملكه
للممارسات الاستفزازيه للمسؤول الاسرائيلي
وعبرت الوزاره في بيان عن اسف المملكه لما
تقوم به اسرائيل من ممارسه فوائد تقود
وجود السلام الدوليه
وتتعارض مع المبادئ والاعراف الدوليه في
احترام المقدسات الدينيه هذا واستدعت
وزاره الخارجيه الاردنيه سفيره الاسرائيلي
للاحتجاج على اقتحام بن غفير للمسجد
الاقصى فيما عرضت مصر والامارات والكويت
وقطر وجامعه الدول العربيه عن ادانه
الاقتحام
في غضون ذلك اعرب مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي عن رفضه لاي عمل احادي يقود
عمليه السلام في الشرق الاوسط واكد المجلس
وان واشنطن تاوي تؤيد بقوه الحفاظ على
الوضع القائم مع احترام المواقع المقدسه
في القدس
وتطالب او تطالبوا
نتنياهو بالالتزام بتعهداتته بالحفاظ على
الوضع القائم للمواقع المقدسه
في هذه الاثناء قال رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو ان حكومته
ستعمل على منع العوده الى الاتفاق نووي مع
ايران واحيائه وفقا لشروط طهران
يوتيوب
بعد الاحداث الاخيره في ايران اعتقد ان
هذا الاتفاق لم يشطب عن الطاوله بعد لذلك
لمنع العوده الى هذا الاتفاق السيء الذي
يؤدي الى ايران نوويه برعايه دوليه كما
سنعمل بجديه اكبر على منع المؤسسه
العسكريه الايرانيه في سوريا واماكن اخرى
ولا ننتظر
يتسلم الجمهوريون اليوم الاغلبيه الرسميا
من الديمقراطيين في مجلس النواب مع افتتاح
اعمال الكونجرس الجديد ويستعد الجمهوريون
لفتح جبهه مواجهه ضد الرئيس الامريكي
جوبيزن هي الاولى منذ تنصيبه حيث توعدوا
بمحاسبه البيض في ملفات عده ابرزها الحرب
في اوكرانيا والمنافسه مع الصين والانسحاب
من افغانستان بالاضافه الى اليه التعامل
مع وباء كرونه وسيتعين على بيض التعامل مع
برلمان منقسم بين حزب الديمقراطي الذي
يتمتع بالسيطره على مجلس الشيوخ والمعارضه
الجمهوريه التي فازت بغالبيه ضئيله في
مجلس النواب ويرى الاعضاء الجمهوريون ان
الامريكيين مستعدون لبدايه تحول بعد عامين
كريستيين تحت قياده الحزب الديمقراطي
ومع ذلك فالعائق الذي قد يعطل المواجهه
المرتقبه مع بيضا ما يتعلق بالانتفاخ مع
بين الجمهوريين انفسهم على انتخابي رئيسا
لمجلس النواب في وقت يعاني الحزب من
انقسامات قويه في صفوفه وفقا للتقارير
الامريكيه
معي من واشنطن مراسل العربيه حسين توضح
حسين اهلا بك اختيار بديل لفيلوزي هذا
الموضوع سيكون الملف الابرز متى نتوقعوا
صباح الخير ريما بتوقيتنا بالفعل هو الملف
الابرز للجلسه الاولى اليوم لمجلس النواب
في الامريكي في دورته ال 118
حتى الان كيف المقارتي لم يضمن الاصوات
الكافيه لحصوله على هذا المنصب هو من
المفروض ان يحصل على 218 صوتا ولكن هناك
معارضه قويه من قبل عدد من الجمهوريين
ثلاثه جمهوريين اكدوا انهم سيصوطون ضدهم
هو لا يستطيع ان يخسر اكثر من اربع
جمهوريين يصوطون ضدهم اذا صوت بعضهم من من
يعارضه همم
بانه حاضر امتنع عن التصويت طبعا عتبه
الاصوات المطلوبه لحصوله على منصب رئيس
مجلس النواصه تنخفض ولكن هو حتى الان لم
يضمن ذلك من يعارضه لا يقولون انه سيصوتون
ضده او سيمتنعون عن التصويت لذلك همم هو
يعني بعد نحو ساعتين ونص تقريبا على
الساعه الثانيه عشر ستكون الج وسيتم همم
التصويت على انتخاب مكارتي او لا اذا لكن
هنا جبنا نذكر وان نشير الى انه اذا لم
يتم انتخابه ستعاد عمليه الانتخابات اكثر
من مره ولكن عندها ستكون هذه المره الاولى
منذ 100 عام همم بان يتم همم تفتح الجلسه
الاولى ولا يتم انتخاب رئيس مجلس النواب
بعد الانتخابات هذه همم حدثت عام اخر مره
عام
الوضع حتى الان هو تحليلات كلها تقول بانه
قد لا يستطيع كذا المكرسي بالفعل الحصول
على هذه الاصوات طيب وننتظر يعني انعكاس
اكبر للانقسام الجمهوري داخل مجلس النواب
بين مؤيدين بدنا ترامب همم بين من يؤيد
نفسه في الكثير من التحليلات ليوم الحديث
السابقه بالتاريخ الحديث للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه اود ان اعلم ما هي الاليه يعني
اليوم في حال لم يتم
نتوقع ماذا التصويت اول ثاني ثالث الى اي
ااا متى يعني الى متى تستمر التصويت
اول والثاني والثالثه سيبقى هناك تصويت
حتى يتم انتخاب رئيس
سابقات طبعا منذ مئه عام وقبل ذلك ااه بعض
التصبيطات بقت لاشهر حتى تم تعيين رئيس
مجلس نواب او انتخاب رئيس مجلس النواب
العمليه طويله قد تكون طويله اذا لم يتم
الاتفاق عليها ولكن هناك من يرى من
المحللين الجمهوريين بان مكه ان لم ينجح
في المره الاولى سينجح من خلال همم
التصويطات الثانيه التي ستجر لان
الجمهوريين الان باتم يشعرون ويحسنون
بانهم بانهم
يضعفهم امام همم الديمقراطيين لذلك في
نهايه المطافقون على حل ما اذا قدم مكار
في المزيد من الضمانات هو كان قدم قبل
ايام ضمانات لعدد من الجمهوريين الذين
طالبوا بان مثلا يعطيهم همم يؤكد لهم اليه
همم
تمكنهم من اقاله او الاطاحه مجلس النواب
هذه اعطاها لهم لكن هو لم يقدم ضمانه من
حيث دعم الجمهوريين في الانتخابات
التمهيديه لانهم طالبه بان لا بانه ك-
رئيسه المجلس النواب اللا يتدخل بدعم
الحسبه الجمهوري في الانتخابات التمهيديه
هذه لم يعطيها لهم لذلك تسعه نواب
جمهوريون قالوا بانكرتي لم يعطي الضمانات
اللازمه الان اذا تذكرته تنازل عن هذه
الضمانات كما تنازل عن بعضها قد يتم
الاتفاق حوله ويتم انتخابه في المحاوله
الثانيه له بعد محاوله عام 2015
على الارض شكرا لك حتى لحظه من واشنطن
مراسل على العربيه حسين التوت
يمكن المؤسسه اكس اكس
على عملاء ومستثمرين في بورصه العملات
المقاطعه الامريكيه في منحاته وقد وجهت
الى بنك تهمه الاحتلال الكتروني وسته
التهام بتامر بما في ذلك غسل الاموال حيث
يمكن ان يواجه ما يصل الى 115 سنه من
السجن وتفيد دعوه قضائيه رفعت الشهر
الماضي بان اف تي اكس مدينه بمبلغ يصل الى
اكثر من ثلاثه مليارات دولار ل 50 دائما
من عملائها
وتتابعونا في الخامسه ولكن بعد لحظات
عمال السكك الحديديه ببريطانيا يبداون
اضرابا ومخاوف من اضطرابات كبرى لحركه
القطارات
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلن المرصد السوري
لحقوق الانسان عن مقتل عنصرين من قوات
سوريا ديمقراطيه قصد واصابه اخر جراء قصف
جنته طائره مسيره تركيه على موقع بمدينه
الحسكه في سوريا ويعدوا هذا القصف الثاني
للقوات التركيه خلال الساعات الماضيه
[موسيقى]
تواجه بريطانيا هذا الاسبوع اعرف سلسله من
اضرابات عمال الحديديه بدايه من اليوم
ولمده خمسه ايام
وغلاء المعيشه
وتجسد الاضطرابات صعيدا اخر في النساء
المتزايد بين النقابات والحكومه على
الاجور بحسب صحيفه السلجراف قبل ذلك كان
المتحدث باسم رئيس الحكومه البريطانيه
قال ان المملكه المتحده تستعد لاضطرابات
الهائله مستمره بسبب الاضرابات واوضح ان
الحكومه ترغب في انهاء الازمه لكنها تعارض
زيادات المرتفعه للاجور بمعدلات عشريه
قائلا ان ذلك سيؤدي الى تفاقم معدلات
التضخم
من لندن مراسل العربيه مصطفى زارو مصطفى
اهلا بك هل نتحدث عن اضراب القطارات ترينز
او تيوب سترايك يعني المترو الانفاق او
يشمل مترو الانفاق
هو حقيقه هو الاضراب فقط
للقطارات التي تربط المدن وايضا بعض
المناطق المجاوره للمدن الكبرى ولكن مترو
انفاق لندن سيكون له تاثير محدود بسبب
تشارك
قطاع النقل لسكك الحديد في بعض المناطق
يعني مثلا بالنسبه هناك خمسه خطوط ستتاثر
منها
بالاضافه الى خط السيركل الذي هو في وسط
لندن وايضا بعض يعني التوقف القطارات في
بعض الخطوط خاصه مثلا بالنسبه لخط لخط
الاخضر او ما ما يعرف لكن هذه الاضطرابات
كانت متوقعه بسبب بسبب اسرار نقابه
العاملين في سكك الحديد على الاستجابه على
استجابه الحكومه لمطالبه وان كانت
المفاوضات هي بين همم نقابه عمال الحديد
والمشغلي هذه همم القطارات هناك اربعه 10
همم شركه تدير هذه الرحلات يبدو انها في
وقت ما توصلت الى تسويه ولكن بحسب نقبه
سكك الحديد بان الحكومه تدخلت لوقف هذه
التسويه بسبب رفع الاجور التي ربما ستزيد
من نسبه التضخم وكما تعلمين ريما بان همم
اولويات ريش السوناتا عندما تعهد به
باستلام السلطه كانت احدى اولوياته وهو
سيطره على التضخم لان التضخم هو مصدر قلق
وارتفاع اسعار المواد الغذائيه همم
غلاء المعيشه بشكل
هي فعلا دوامه للعجله الاقتصاديه التي تقع
فيها الحكومات عاده طيب مصطفى همم اسئله
سريعه اولا ما هو وضع الحدود هل
لا بادراب لحراس الحدود والهجره ام انه
توقف يبدو انه الجيش همم نجح هذه التجربه
هل يمكن استدعاء الجيش ايضا للقطارات
ومترو الانفاق
حتى ليست في في ترتيبات الحكومه ولكن
بالنسبه لقوات الحدود ليست هناك اي
ترتيبات اخرى للاضراب ولكن يبدو بان تدخل
الحكومه باستخدام عناصر من الجيش وايضا
لموظفين مدنيين همم
يعملون في مختلف الوزاره خاصه وزاره
الداخليه ربما قاموا بعمل افضل من حراس
الحدود بحسب فعلا
التقيناهم في وقت سابق همم وصل الى مطار
هيثرو قالوا يعني العمليه كانت همم
الثالثه وسريعه لم تكن هناك طوابير طويله
فقط كانت بعض المشاكل فيما في ما يتم
باستلام حقائب المسافرين ولكن عدد ذلك
الامور يعني طيب لم يكن متوقع ان كنا
جميعا كنا نتوقع بان تكون هناك فوضه كبيره
للمسافرين الذين همم
المتحده او الذين يغادر اهلا اهلا مخالف
تماما نعم اذا اسبوع صعب جدا امام
المقاومين مقيمين في بريطانيا يعطيك الف
عافيه انت وفريق العمل مصطفى زارو مراسل
العرب
اعلنت الخارجيه الصينيه تتخذوا الاجراءات
المناسبه ضد الدول التي فرضت قيود الدخول
على المسافرين المصريين بسبب تفشي كورونا
مشيره الى ان قرار تلك الدولي يفتقر الى
الاساس العلمي واصفه اياه بغير المبرر
وتعهدات باتخاذ ما يلزم للرد عليها
للتغلب على رائحه كرونه لكننا نعتقد ان
قيود الدخول التي فرضتها بعض الدول على
الصين تفتقر الى الاساس العلميه وبعض
الممارسات غير المقبوله الصين تعارض بشده
محاولات التلاعب باجراءات الوقايه من
الوباء ومكافحته لاغراض سياسيه وسنتخذ
الاجراءات المناسبه وفقا لمبدا المعاملته
بالمثل
الحمد لله
[موسيقى]
قاعده مكتب الرئاسه الكوريه الجنوبيه
تاكيد ان صول واشنطن تناقشان اجراء
مناورات نوويه مشتركه للاسلحه النوويه
الامريكيه لمواجهه التهديدات المتناويه
المتناميه من كوريا الشماليه بعد ما نفع
الرئيس الامريكي جو بيدن ان يكون هناك مثل
هذه التدريبات المشتركه
بين اقرار ونفي مناورات النوويه مشتركه
على وشك البدر الولايات المتحده وحليفتها
كوريا الجنوبيه تناقشان اجراء مناورات
النوويه المشتركه للاسلحه النوويه
الامريكيه لمواجهه التهديدات المتناميه من
كوريا الشماليه هذا ما تاكده صول وتنفيه
وسلطه
الامنيان يجريان محدثاتهم بشان تشارك
معلومات
مشتركه في ما يتعلق بتشغيل الاسلحه
النوويه الامريكيه للرد على الاسلحه
النوويه لكوريا
من قبل الرئيس الكوري الجنوبي الذي اقر في
مقابله صحفيه ان واشنطن تتلقى فكره
تدريبات المشتركه للاسلحه النوويه بطريقه
ايجابيه
للرئيس الامريكي رايه المعاكس لنظيره
الكوري الجنوبي حيث نفى في اجابه على سؤال
من صحفيين في البيت الابيض عما اذا كان
يناقش حاليا اجراء تدريبات النوويه مشتركه
مع كوريا الجنوبيه نفي اخر جاء من مسؤول
امريكي في واشنطن اكد ان بلاده لن تقوم
باجراء مناورات نوويه مشتركه مع كوريا
الجنوبيه لانها ليست قوه النوويه
تصريحات متضاربه تاتي بعد دعوه الرئيس
الكوري الشمالي الى تطوير صواريخ باليستيه
جديده عابره للقارات وزياده هائله في
ترسانه بلاده النوويه بما يشمل الانتاج
الضخم لاسلحه تكتيكيه وتطوير صواريخ جديده
لاستخدامها في ضربات مضاده ملوك الشيخ
العربي
خطوات اكثر جديه لتحقيق التوافق البيئي
والحفاظ على شعاب المرجانيه الاغلى في
العالم من الاثار والتغيرات البيئيه
والمناخيه
لتنفي الاتهامات التي وجهت لشركات بترول
بتدمير الطبيعه في خليج السويس ابو العزم
والتفاصيل
في خليج السويس وعلى بعد
350 كيلو مترا من القاهره تعمل ستات بترول
في مجال التنقيب فضلا عن معملين في مجال
التكرير شركات تعمل على مدى عقود اتهمت
مؤخرا بتدمير الشعب المرجانيه في البحر
الاحمر اتهام ضحضه وزير البترول ووزيره
البيئه من خلال جوله وشرح علميه لما يتم
اتخاذه من اجراءات للمحافظه على البيئه
وعلى تلك الشع التي تعد الاغني عالميا
الصرف الصناعي البترولي وكمان في كمان خطط
استكمال
لهذه المنظومه وفي نفس الوقت لم يتم
التاثير السلبي على الشعب المرجانيه اا
ولازم كمان نقول انه الشباب المرجانيه مش
في مصر في العالم كله حصل لها بعض
التغيرات نتيجه
الاحتباس الحراري
وسخونه مياه البحار وبعض العوامل اخرى زي
المخلفات البلاستيكيه وبعض الانشطه
البحريه الاخرى ليست لها علاقه بالانشطه
البتروليه احنا يمكن الشكل واللون بتاعه
الشعاب المرجانيه اللي شفناها لايف من
ساعتين ودلوقتي موجوده برده وجوه
للكاميرات اللي موجوده تحت الميه بتورينا
ان حصل تعافي سريع في الشعاب المرجانيه
اللي موجوده في هذا المكان بس ملتزمت
بمخرجات مؤتمر المناخ كوب سبع سنوات والذي
عقد مؤخرا في شرم الشيخ ومن بينها خفض
الانبعاثات من غاز الميثان وتحقيق الحياد
الصفري فضلا عن وضع خطط للاصحاح البيئي
لشركات البترول العامله في خليج السويس
وعمل محطات معالجه للصرف الصناعي ومشروعات
تعد الاولى من نوعها بتكلفه 400 مليون
دولار يعني انا النهارده بدل مقرمي الميه
بتاعه الصرف الصناعي اللي مش متعالجه على
البحر انا ضريت البحر واحضرت الميه طب انا
افردي عالجتها وعرفت ادخلها ثاني في
العمليات الانتاجيه يبقى بالتالي انا وفرت
لنفسي اقتصاديه ففكره ربطه البيئه
بالاقتصاد يمكن هو ده التوجه اللي احنا
بداناه من ثلاث اربع سنين اه قد التحدي
امام الحفاظ على البيئه مع استمرار
التنميه وحل مشاكل ترى كانت منذ اكثر من
اربعه عقود بدات مصر ضغطته في حلها بجديه
منذ نحو اربعه اعوام باست تكنولوجيا حديثه
وخطط عمل قصيره وطويله الاجل لمنع التلوث
والتصدي لاي انعكاسات سلبيه من اي حادث
راند ابو العزم العربيه رش قير خليج
السويس
نشره المساء شكرا المتابعه الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]